[Musique]
c'est dans une cité populaire de la
banlieue d'alger et que vit le mannequin
le plus célèbre du pays et yasmine elle
a 19 ans et la grandit sur ses airs de
guitare
son père est un admirateur d'enrico
macias et grands
et croise ici tous les partis impliqués
notre quotidien ça lui arrive souvent de
prendre sa guitare
yasmine est interprète mais elle a
surtout été élue miss alger il y a un
nom sont bientôt les siens nine sur le
podium et la drogue rhodia
les facteurs en 1994
des tracts promettait la mort à toute
femme non voilée yasmine ne s'y est pas
soumise ces parents sont libéraux mais
elle ne sort jamais seul
[Applaudissements]
départ en tout cas bon jovi mary j
cette échappée
mais la petite foule l option
attention
mais voilà si on veut
peut-être que ça va je mettrai le roi
quand je serai plus âgés vous parle
pas encore
ce qui est
tartas
et ici
se passait mal
c'est que c'était écrit voilà
mektoub le destin une fatalité qui
depuis dix ans peut exploser à chaque
coin de rue
[Musique]
cela fait dix ans que la guerre a
commencé en algérie une guerre civile
elle aurait déjà fait plus de cent mille
morts ceux qui ont aujourd'hui 20 ans
ont grandi dans cette violence ils ont
vécu leur adolescence entre assassinat
bombe et massacres a alger on les
appelle la génération du terrorisme
comme tous les week-ends ryad et ses
amis sont de sortie ils se sont donné
rendez-vous à staouéli une petite ville
à 25 km d'alger
c'est souvent là que démarre les nuits
avant d'aller en boîte
en 1997 une bombe avait explosé ici cela
n'empêche pas les gens de continuer à y
venir
pourtant en algérie les terroristes sont
loin d'avoir baissé les bras
pendant notre reportage les journaux ont
continué à égrainer la litanie des
massacres la terreur la stratégie de la
peur
de mon frère
on meurt tôt ou tard en meurent
nombre de chèques seulement six joueurs
dans une bande rouge s'est pas tué par
une balle perdue quoi que ce soit ces
risques de la vie hein
il ya une bonne part entière et quand
voir le résultat
le duo raconter une toute petite
anecdote zimmo avec les deux fers de
l'ena sur la tête
baïla il a été enfin dans un train et
pour les mêmes bancs il est resté six
jours aux communs
la preuve est en train de savourer une
glace ça doit pas l'empêcher de vivre à
la faille passer
c'est arrivé subitement une bande sur
[Musique]
500 dinars l'entrée donnant droit à une
boisson alcoolisée un dixième du smic
la sélection se fait rapidement le raïs
hamidou club n'a jamais fermé
même au plus fort du terrorisme il est
l'un des lieux favoris de la jeunesse
dorée des jeunes gens des deux sexes six
rencontres
la discothèque ne désemplit pas
[Musique]
salle effectivement de leur forme est
passé à lécher leur copie
voilà ta déversant c'est que les mecs et
relationnel à récupérer l'événement et
août
c'est mérité
[Musique]
le refrain on ne vit qu'une fois ils le
reprennent en coeur comme un manifeste
[Musique]
sa mère a pu manger
ça s'est arrangé
et
pour le moment les choses ne se sont pas
tout à fait arranger
[Musique]
réd
étudiante futurs ingénieurs en
informatique à 21 ans gagnât et
journaliste à la radio algérienne
elle anime en kabyle l'une des langues
nationales
une émission musicale très populaire
parmi les jeunes ajoute l'europe elle
est un local où il est ou non car si ce
n'est la république dépresseurs
l'antiquité une bouteille je suis en
picardie nixon traction lycée régulière
l'eau douce est la leur nous aidera le
disque à la guinée et dizaines de noirs
et aux schémas rubrique qui s'appelle
le bouquet parce que cette émission pour
moi est conçu cette pige jardin que je
protège mois la production est un jardin
qui lie à kiel dont sept jardins il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de grèves dites moi
qu'il faut les protéger
il ya même temps d'étonnant les fleurs
sont fragiles les islamistes en ont
beaucoup fauché à coups de rafales
en 1993 il avait interdit toute musique
autre que les chants religieux
en juin 1998 matoub lounès plus célèbre
chanteur est assassiné plus de 50 balles
crible son corps d'autres artistes ont
été exécutés pourtant chez les
disquaires on trouve leur enregistrement
vous continuez de gens de leur casser on
continue de prendre de l'âge
parce que c'est le public est demandeur
ces gens là c'est bien celle-là des gia
les maisons qu'ils ont une petite
stratégie si on voit la carte
géographique aérienne chaque région
mais son prix
mais l'algérie s'est pas jerry qui a
produit cheval this cheb hasni matoub
lounès elle est en train de produire son
la caisse vive et l'unsa 12 ça allait
pourquoi
alan périodes d assassiner des
journalistes j'étais parmi les gens qui
m'ont nasser dans tous les
les gens qui travaillent la radio mais
je me suis dit un jour que l'amour c'est
une seule fois soit au moins soit en
rachetant
depuis le début de la guerre civile 70
journalistes ont été assassinés
salut coco
comme la moitié des jeunes de son âge
karim et chômeurs pour tuer le temps
karim et ses copains de galère face
leurs journées dans l'immeuble du 90 de
la rue didouche mourad ancienne rue
michelet le 90 comme ils disent leur
quartier général
[Musique]
je plaide t il toujours à madinat al
houdoud rovio oissu patients convoi
soient sûres
[Musique]
karim et son groupe les ras dénonce dans
chansons les conditions de vie de la
jeunesse le thème qui avait permis aux
islamistes leurs succès électoraux
ça va en 1990 les islamistes avaient
gagné dans ce quartier
en 1997 c'est une femme laïque et
démocrate qui a été élu pour les jets
président en 1990 aucune femme n'aurait
osé mettre les pieds dans un café dix
ans plus tard les choses ont changé
[Musique]
selon la présidente
elle est devenue folle qui l'ont
assassiné ses cinq as
[Musique]
cinquante cinq garçons
elle concluait son mari elle était
normal un jour elle est devenue folle
mes enfants elle qui est la halle a trop
pleuré
longtemps 95
c'est dans cette région à 20 km à l'est
d'alger que hassan hattab l'un des chefs
terroristes les plus sanguinaires a fait
régner la terreur nous sommes dans son
fief à benzerga racket violent massacre
ici on n'est pas prêt d'oublier la
violence intégriste
malgré les risques ghania seront partout
où des femmes souffrent et les
militantes de rajda l'association
féminine qui se posent aux diktats des
islamistes elle a rendez vous avec une
famille défavorisée pour faire
l'inventaire des livres des fournitures
scolaires et des vêtements
indispensables pour la rentrée des
classes
la femme qui la reçoit a été jeté à la
rue après 28 ans de mariage son mari
avait la justice de son côté il l'a
légalement répudier avec leurs huit
enfants
ensuite il l'a harcelé jusque dans le
bidonville où elle s'était réfugiée
finalement attentif et savait tout cela
dit s'être fait avoir des touches
finalement s'arrêter pour ça plaide
celle qu'un médicament 126,6 me dit non
elle va lui donner six mille dinars
c'est marrant tu rates et fatima champ
mahmoud jibril ne l'annoncé recul mollet
on va faire des tirages sur des choses
pareils comme ça ne les ayez les nerfs
canonné dans la revue matinale des siens
il ya belle ou le clonage des machines
est un jour je décide de marier je me
retrouve avec un code donnant et qui ne
voudrait pas dire formation leur côté
elles rapport il me faut une
autorisation d'accusation
si c'est la honte alors atteindre l je
pense à notre chaîne youtube depuis 1984
le code de la famille fait de la femme
une mineure elle doit obéissance à son
mari
la polygamie et la répudiation sont
légales en justice
le témoignage d'une femme vaut la moitié
de celui d'un homme on est loin de
l'égalité des sexes
inscrite dans la constitution a alger le
vendredi c'est notre dimanche le jour de
la prière pour les jeunes chômeurs il
n'y a rien à faire
comme tout est fermé en ville on
s'échappe
karim a un copain qui a une voiture
c'est peut-être la future mère de billy
joel et à al hilal a pris à bail des
coulées à genoux tragique du tout
apprécié
[Musique]
à 30 kilomètres d'alger la plage ouest
vous aimez venir ici rabat
[Musique]
je suis un
des soldats
[Rires]
c'est la jauge
ce soir
en 1990 après leur victoire aux
élections les islamistes avaient essayé
d'interdire sur les plages la mixité et
le port du maillot de bain ils ont
échoué
plus tard ils ont tout simplement
interdit ces plages trois jours après
notre tournage une bombe a explosé sur
celle de bab el oued
malgré cela certains week end il est
presque impossible de poser sa serviette
d'après les sauveteurs chargés de
surveiller la baignade l'été dernier
plus de 23 millions de personnes se sont
rendues sur les plages des environs
d'alger
on a passé une période grave et on l'a
passé quand même on l'a passée cette
période chaque génération de jeux soit
trop tard mais la période de sursis
vraiment le gras
quand tu vois tes frères égorger les ce
meeting par des dons des figures les
gars c'est vrai ça nous a touchés mais
on a passé de la période
c'est bonjour dinars
[Musique]
m
l'hôtel international ce cinq étoiles
vient d'ouvrir une nouvelle discothèque
le boum boum club
ryad a décidé d'y organiser un défilé de
mode
cela fait deux jours qu'il prépare ses
mannequins ce sont tous des amateurs
[Musique]
et parmi ces mannequins yasmine miss
alger comme d'habitude yasmina un
chaperon quelqu'un qui ne la lâche pas
des yeux lorsqu'elle est avec un garçon
à la la petite soeur son chaperon du
jour
non
regardez
pour ryad c'est un grand jour il veut
ouvrir une agence de mannequins ce
défilé est son premier grand pas
elle
[Musique]
pensez à jour des messages
une semaine
l'idée qui était venu de se présenter
sous un toit ou c'est quelqu'un à blâmer
je suis allé en tant que mannequin
proposait de passe est en cours je
serais passé
je compte 1,1 à réaction de ma mère ça
va ça fait quelque chose
partant d'un enchantement
oui très important j'ai vu ma mère fière
de moi au boum boum club
il faut montrer patte blanche les
propriétaires veulent en faire le lieu
le plus sélect de la capitale
on leur demande d'essai des armes au
vestiaire
c'est pour la sécurité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tiré par les cheveux
[Applaudissements]
des coiffeuses des couturières des
maquilleuses ont été égorgés par des
groupes islamistes
tout ce qui pouvait mettre en valeur la
féminité pour les terroristes ce qui
sort de l'uniforme intégristes doit
disparaître sans vraiment s'en rendre
compte
yasmine et les autres mannequins font de
la résistance loin des paillettes en
plein centre ville
karim le rappeur vite avec sa famille
dans cet immeuble construit au début du
siècle
dix personnes dont trois pièces son père
sa mère deux frères ses soeurs deux
nièces et neveux son frère aîné est le
seul à avoir un emploi
son père ancien combattants du fln a
obtenu cet appartement juste après
l'indépendance
car avec la connais par coeur ça très
malheureux le génie si tel est vraiment
le mof sa vision du voyage à l'intérieur
de la tige de bois je croyais être une
chômage
il n'y a aucun légume par moments mais
peut-être que j'y suis c'est la
meilleure chose comme tous les autres
parents le père de karim se sent désarmé
il n'a pas les moyens de faire grand
chose pour aider ses enfants
oui
non
de vos longues encore
la mère dont mes soeurs normal qu'elles
sont vraies cela je respecte mon père je
respecte mon frère ce qu'on trouve des
tarifs au maire elle craint comprend un
accès normal de 19,6
[Applaudissements]
ça les coquettes ça va la coquetterie la
légèreté la solution pour ne pas sombrer
[Musique]
la kasbah le plus vieux quartiers
d'alger l'unesco l'a classé patrimoine
mondial de l'humanité
la kasbah a été un fief islamiste dans
le dédale des ruelles les groupes armés
ont fait régner la terreur après chacune
de leurs opérations
ils s'évanouissaient sautant de terrasse
en terrasse
au petit matin il était fréquent de
découvrir des têtes décapitées plantés
sur les grilles des mosquées
pour gagne à la journaliste la casbah
n'a pas de secret c'est dans ce
labyrinthe que sa famille s'est
installée au siècle dernier et dans
notre maison notre chère maison c'est
c'est à la raison
de malibu qui habite mon cousin et
or on revend tout ses parents ont fait
la guerre d'indépendance son grand oncle
yassef saadi fut le héros de la bataille
d'alger et son cousin le petit homard et
le plus jeunes martyrs de la guerre
je veux voir ses enfants qui s'exprime
en toute liberté ça soit à l'intérieur
de chez elle s'assoit à l'extérieur
qu'elle puisse mener sa vie dans la bo
limitation qu'elle puisse donner son
savoir à ses enfants et non clôturés
derrière rien vous le derrière une tare
de l'atelier un hall dexter
notre espoir c'est d'avoir no frills
audace ans sur le même niveau c'est à
dire sont de même niveau de vie
culturelle avant on pouvait passer d'une
maison eyes c'est-à-dire 2000 voisins
surtout les femmes nous étions violent
surtout les femmes c'est au même niveau
qu on se souvient surtout les femmes
quand elle voulait rendre visite et pas
la peine qu'ils descendent dans la rue
pour entrer chez leur voisin alan ladd
fermeté de sauter de vue est passé et
maintenant
et maintenant par le besoin de sécurité
bien j'ai tout bouclé je veux à la
surface de la piscine de l'agacement
pourquoi tant breton foulard
longtemps cantonné par contre en famille
on n'est pas fous là entre nantes
oui c'est comme ça c'est vouloir pesage
et jamie pour me protéger un peu pour
vous protéger de cette passe quand nous
avons n'oublie pas nous avons vécu un
moment très difficile à vivre c'est pour
ça c'est ça que nous sommes obligés de
faire des choses même si on veut pas
mais obligés de les faire c'est
peut-être scène et je vais gérer c'est
ça la vraie réalité de la majorité de
jeunes filles algériennes
les nuits de rêve de sidi ferruch toutes
les nuits d'été des concerts de 22h à 5h
du matin un festival très réputé
pour karim et les ras leur premier
concert public
il passe en ouverture ce sont deux qui
vont démarrer la soirée
ils vont devoir chauffer la scène alors
que la reine est loin d'être pleine
[Musique]
pour leur premier concert ils ne sont
pas gâtés ils doivent improviser avec un
disc jockey qui ne connaît pas leurs
chansons
[Musique]
la samarie
la sono est mauvaise et surtout la
musique choisie par le disc jokeys ne va
pas le public réagit peu qu'ils étaient
téléphonique d'un cri écoute bien laver
des gens qui dansent en l'état
c'est bon
pour nous je compte vraiment
pas
[Musique]
entre temps les gradins se sont remplies
pour chadli asile la star du raï
[Musique]
mais m
le rap n'est pas encore très populaire
c'est toujours le rail qui fait tanguer
les foules algéroise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]